[Music] Mr. Claude It must be a white school It's a
prestigious school
Even the demon king was wondering what to do if a stone was thrown It
's almost
time for the next meeting No
, I want to know the inside of the school
I need to prepare for Assart's attack
I can't attack
anything There's no way there's a monster worthy of a king
Bell Don't throw away your preconceptions and think You
can
do it Come to think of it, there's
something I want to ask Is there a duck student at this school
?  If it's
not lunchtime yet, the headmaster will show you to the
cafeteria
[Music]
Serena
must be longing for the maiden of the government, right?
Uh, that's fine, but
I'm begging you, Serena, can you
guide me? Yes, I'll leave
it up to
you
.
[music]
That face is still insane, but